[Musique]
et
il est grand il est il et il est musclé
c'est un corps d'athlète une tête de
tête d'acteur et puis et puis un esprit
très très faim comme on dit des ondes
latin mens sana in corpore sano c'est
alexis maloubier c'est le directeur du
golf de saint quentin en yvelines du
golf blue green de saint quentin en
yvelines un des premiers grands golf
public peut-être des plus fréquentés de
france pour jour à louviers ça vous
voient comme un présentation si vous
êtes ce costaud un gentil
ben justement vous avez à craindre comme
ça une sorte de corps d'athlète comme
beaucoup vous n'êtes ni au golf pourquoi
le golf plutôt que l'athlétisme c'est
pas le rugby justement réduire le golf
ccni sort assez assez singulière chez
moi j'ai commencé j'avais 13 14 ans fait
beaucoup de sport beaucoup de judo très
bon en judo du rugby du basket et je me
suis déchiré les ligaments de la
cheville gauche en faisant du bassin est
finalement le seul sport que je pouvais
faire plâtrer style golf et mon père
avait un client qui joue au golf il m'a
emmené taper quelques balles j'ai trouvé
ça génial la sensation de taper cette
balade est allé rnipp dans la nature et
voilà j'ai trouvé ça vraiment incroyable
comme sport et donc plâtré basse était
le seul sport que je pouvais faire des
choses comme ça voilà une excellente 90
ça fait pas mal quand même aux gens
adoptent le prof était un peu fou parce
que je suis rentrée dans l'école de golf
assez rapidement il allait très très
peur que je me fasse membres élus ce mal
mais moi j'adorais ça c'est un peu comme
un fou et voila voila c'était sympa
c'était mes premiers pas dans google et
les premiers pas au continue puisque
vous êtes devenu professionnel oui su
passer pro j'avais une vingtaine
d'années assez jeune et j'ai enseigné
pendant une bonne dizaine d'années ouais
voilà les c'était une bonne expérience
c'était super draine un métier
passionnant j'adorais monter les jeunes
le créer des écoles de golf m'occuper
des gens et quelque part contribuer à
leur bonheur au quotidien parce que le
golf c'est un sport qui donne beaucoup
de bonheur et qui peut aussi donner
beaucoup de tristesse quand ça va pas et
voilà j'ai fait ça pendant une dizaine
d'années vous êtes vos formateurs
c'était quelqu'un qui a
des grands noms du golf c'est dominique
larretche oui alors j'ai eu dominique
que me comme formateur au départ jean
delgado et j'en étais ma fille beaucoup
de chance d'avoir
trois personnalités du golfe généreuse
et les grands entraîneurs de non plus
deux
et comment vous êtes passés de de
l'enseignement la meinau jeudi vous êtes
directeur d'école de
bluegreen de saint quentin en yvelines
c'est pas le premier golf que vous
dirigez non c'est le quatrième j'ai eu
une opportunité il ya une dizaine
d'années enfin une opportunité pas
vraiment mais le départ d'un directeur
et un nouveau directeur qui devait
arriver qui est jamais venu j'ai pris un
petit peu les commandes du site dans
lequel j'étais à cette époque là et la
direction du groupe a décidé finalement
de me placer
la direction de ce groupe qui était à
guerville à l'époque de la charente la
jolie et où g voilà je me suis occupé du
golfe pas trop mal et après jamais pris
un euro depuis un autre et j'ai fini ici
est elle finie
et elle le fait d'être plutôt dans des
bureaux complet vers
très clairement j'essaye d'être le moins
possible j'essaie d'être au maximum au
contact avec mes clients et au contact
de mes collaborateurs du terrain parce
que
le secret d'un golf c'est le golfe avant
tout donc il faut avoir un bon parcours
il faut que l'herbe soit entretenue bien
tondue que les collaborateurs se sentent
bien et voilà tu as vécu sur le terrain
pour que le golfeur après soit le plus
heureux possible et on va en parler
parce qu'elle vous avez fait beaucoup
d'efforts justement à 50 à pau pour
refaire le golf de très très bons
niveaux de très haut niveau c'est gentil
mais vous regardez tous vous dites qu'un
là bas il faudrait peut-être un peu
coupé le rêve c'est aussi le boulot d'un
tiers soit c'est effectivement faut être
un peu sur tous les fronts et surtout se
mettre à la place du golfeur parce que
les gars du terrain vont faire le
maximum pour donner entre guillemets
leurs compétences techniques sur les
vignes et herbes et moi avec mon petit
passive de le joueur de golf de profs de
golf on va dire ce qui est intéressant
c'est que je vais apporter plus un deuil
de golfeurs en essayant de trouver les
petites choses qui donneront entre
guillemets le plus de résultats pour le
jeu derrière pour nous pour nos golfeurs
alors je disais saint quentin le doc de
la base de loisirs de saint quentin
reading qui appartient au groupe blue
green qui est un des plus grands groupes
ii de golf en france enfin tout à fait
peut-être peut-être dans le monde je
sais pas en tout cas en france ce su
ça a été un des premiers golf public
faut dire que dans les années 80 quand
ça a été créé il y avait des golf privé
coûter très cher et il fallait être
membre
il n'y avait pas de golf vous pouvez
aller jouer sans en être membres à tout
à fait certains des premiers ça donc
avec un public un peu nouveau couac est
arrivé ah oui parce que les gens
connaissaient pas le golf effectivement
c'était réservé à l'époque à une élite
et l'adn de bluegreen c'est d'essayer de
démocratiser au maximum ce sport et le
rendre accessible au plus grand nombre
et c'est vrai que depuis quelques années
maintenant on fait des initiations
gratuites pour que les gens puissent
venir tester le golf est ce que
finalement voilà ont pu rentrer dans un
golf ya pas de problème les gens vont
être accueillis on va leur faire essayer
et on a depuis quelques années créé des
formules
extrêmement adapté aux débutants et
surtout avec un rapport qualité prix qui
est très intéressant ce qui permet aux
gens de se mettre au golf on va dire
pour aller
moins de 90 euros par mois aujourd'hui
quelqu'un peut se mettre au golf avec du
matériel des cours et un accès au
parcours qui changent énormément par
rapport
aux années il ya une vingtaine d'années
où c'était vraiment oui j'ai directement
en tout cas figurent aussi la tipp qui
devaient se retrouver ce oui ça ça va
marcher ça marche la démocratisation
beaucoup d'efforts aussi alors il ya la
démocratisation du golf marche parce que
on a à peu près depuis quelques années
7000 nouveaux golfeurs en tout cas chez
nous un chez blue green parents non
conformes beaucoup beaucoup de nouveaux
golfeurs donc ça c'est super on essaye
aussi de former les enfants ça c'est sûr
important parce que on remarque c'est un
sport qui peut se faire très très jeune
le golf l'avantagé c'est que un enfant
de 6 ans peut tout de suite se mettent
au golf c'est aussi un sport qui
convient aux jeunes filles ce qui est ce
qui est assez rare parce que souvent il
ya beaucoup d'hommes viassois qui joue
au golf mais voilà enfin jouer
ça s'est féminisée donc voilà c'est un
sport qui qui mélange qui mélange les
sexes et qui permet aux enfants du avec
des adultes aux hommes de jouer avec des
femmes oui tout le monde peut jouer avec
tout le monde que je avec tout le monde
exactement des plus jeunes avec des plus
vieux des bons avec des débutants et ça
c'est vraiment très très chouette et
pour justement les enfants fallait vous
êtes vous fait quoi des désaccords avec
les clés avec les établissements
scolaires exactement par là pour les
plus jeunes il ya deux axes une école de
golf qu'on est en train de re dynamiser
pour essayer d'avoir un maximum
d'enfants et la très récemment depuis la
semaine d'années on a réussi à avoir
quatorze classes de golf scolaire qui
vont venir sur notre site entre mai et
on va dire début juillet donc à travers
un programme
l'éducation nationale et la ligue de
paris donc on va recevoir ses enfants
pour leur donner les premiers rudiments
de golf ou même peut-être leur faire
accéder au parcours parce que certains
commencent déjà dans leur école on a
aussi créé avec des formules de
développement du golf dans les écoles où
on vient avec du matériel dans les
écoles pour enseigner en indoor entre
guillemets le début du golfe voilà et
c'est pas parce que pour les enfants
alors c'est vrai que quelques-uns qui
joue très bien c'est vrai que c'est un
sport ouais il faut quand même
bossé enfin on obtient du plaisir mais
il faut quand même travailler travailler
corps est en même temps c'est peut-être
donner aux enfants des vraies bonnes
valeurs parce que mon dans la vie faut
travailler
voilà c'est un sport qui est merveilleux
bon qui est pas forcément facile mais
comme tout si on travaille si on
s'applique si on est concentré sur ce
qu'on sent très exactement
aux valeurs de respect de concentration
de travail donc c'est quand même
beaucoup de bonnes choses en fait et qui
finalement pour un jeune public donne
voilà un bon pied à l'étrier pour la vie
en fait finalement alors vous parlez d d
d d élève des enfants va desserrer ou
des collégiens il y aussi les étudiants
oui oui tout à fait hors sas et c'est
une population qu'on avait perdue depuis
pas mal d'années on se rend compte que
entre 18 et 25 ans il ya plus personne
donc là on a on a lancé un grand
programme en tout cas à saint quentin en
yvelines
une formule étudiante voilà très bas
coût les étions payés moins de 30 euros
par mois et ça va leur permettre de
jouer au goal d'avoir des courts pendant
un an voilà et ça c'est une grande
nouveauté on a commencé déjà rentré dans
les universités du saint quentinois ben
justement pour promouvoir cette nouvelle
formule en espérant qu'ils aient un
maximum de nouveaux jeunes joueurs qui
viennent chez nous avec un budget adapté
parce qu'on sait que les étudiants oui
ça il sera forcément ton argent et pas
forcément beaucoup d'argent donc voilà
on a essayé de trouver la meilleure
formule la plus adaptée pour qu'il soit
ce plaisir là il dit beaucoup de voile
avec dédé justement des directs dolf
ils disent souvent voilà on a on arrive
ya en effet quelques jeunes qui jouent à
pas mal puisque et puis quand les gens
rentrent dans la vie active qui commence
à bosser qui osera se marier avoir une
famille il ya trou quoi ils reviennent à
50 ans à l'arrêt mais il ya un trou ça
c'est sûr déjà il ya une scène ça vous
le constatez joue il ya l'école de golf
qui reste toujours assez fournie jusqu'à
16 ans pas présent pour les enfants et
effectivement on va dire entre 15 18
jusqu'à 25 ans il ya un énorme trou ça
revient petit peu parce qu'on a sorti à
quelques années des formules pour les
moins de 40 ans pareil avec un budget
plus adaptée du fait qu' effectivement
rentrer dans la vie active
souvent des enfants qui arrivent en bas
âge donc on a essayé de trouver une
formule adaptée pour cette population
plus jeune qui a moins de temps et bien
évidemment après au dessus de 50 60 ans
il ya beaucoup de choses rien n'est
normal c'est normal est ce qu'il y
aurait pas d une des formules qu'il
était tenté de prendre acheter de
devenir à trois trous 4 trous ça a
marché moyennement ah oui parce que
c'est pas forcément dans l'air du temps
et ça a surtout donné quelques
complexité après dans la dans la mise en
oeuvre un parce que les gens qui faisait
trois trous 4 ou 5 trous sur un parcours
parfois se balader à droite à gauche
sans vraiment suivre le même chemin et
ça pouvait créer des petites difficultés
mais c'était quand même l'idée d'essayer
de compresser le temps qu enfin de façon
toutes les idées
toutes les idées sont bonnes à prendre
et toutes ses tentatives toutes façons
ça peut qu être positif pour le monde du
golf parce que voilà effectivement
essayé de jouer plus vite alors y aller
parc ont neuf trous il est compact aussi
qu'ils sont les alternatives et après
les gens souvent maintenant sa bonne et
ça leur permet aussi de jouer que six
trous quand il voit là que se trouve il
ya plusieurs formules on peut verser 6
ans goven filles on peut prendre un
abonnement et si on en prend un
abonnement ça voilà alors j'ai parlé de
parcours de votre attention à ce
parcours c'est vrai que c'est un
parcours très fréquentée donc voilà ça
ne nécessite plus le temps de faire
attention de faire en sorte que là il
est barbu ça commence à être assez joli
way
on arrive à un golf assez aboutie on
rentre dans la saison les greens ont été
ont été travaillés mécaniquement des le
milieu de l'hiver en fait on a pris des
options assez assez risqué cette année
de faire des opérations mécaniques c'est
à faire des trous rajouter du sable en
plein hiver mais s'il est opportuniste
par rapport à la météo et ça nous a
réussi donc ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
mi-avril nos parcours sont dans un état
plus que satisfaisant même si on est
très content j'attends tout à fait
objectif et ça veut dire c'est une
équipe que de quoi vous avez combien de
temps à peu près neuf jardiniers oui on
est en train d'ailleurs d'en recruter un
dixième on sait jamais s'il ya une
vocation qui nous regardent et qui veut
qui veut venir nous rejoindre dans
l'équipe et oui c'est une équipe de près
de dix jardiniers dakhla et plus green
keeper c
est parce que c'est vrai que dans un
ordre qui
comme ce public comme je disais donc
ouvert
il faut tout le temps le remettrons
d'état qu'on fait c'est ça n'arrête
jamais donc qu'il y ait des phases on va
dire de tonte plutôt sur ces périodes
estivales ou ou printanière où l'herbe
pousse beaucoup d période préparatoire
en hiver ou là on va travailler plus le
fond le sol essayer de le rendre plus
drainant
des ajouts de sable avec avec des lames
qui vont casser le sol et on arrête
jamais en fait quelle que soit la saison
à la veille c'était jour de toujours du
boulot ça fait combien ça fait deux ans
que je suis arrivé il ya un an et
vos objectifs c'est quoi à mon objectif
premier était de retrouver rapidement
un très joli parcours est jeté dans la
rue ce qu'on n'est pas loin du résultat
aujourd'hui de développer les jeunes
mise en rayon de créer une belle école
de golf sa chance à très important c'est
l'avenir c'est l'avenir du golf et de
continuer d'ouvrir au plus grand nombre
ce sport qui est vraiment merveilleux
c'est sport d'une vie donc essayer le
faire découvrir voilà découvrir aux
jeunes aux enfants aux moins jeunes à
tout le monde parce que encore une fois
c'est un sport multi générationnel puis
qu'on peut faire un peu tard c'est quoi
faire de sa vie donc ça c'est quand même
c'est quand même merveilleux la ryder
cup
19 et je suis bien 18-18 va y avoir les
jeux olympiques sont toutes régies seth
rogen nationale ça c'est important pour
tous ces événements qui vont mettre en
valeur ce sport ne peut être qu
important parce que le grand public peut
se dire que le golf est un sport un
petit peu pépère un peu plat mais en
fait on a bien vu sur ces événements de
ryder cup cette espèce d engouement
extraordinaire ces gens qui chantaient
dans ce golfe qui était presque devenu
un stade en fait un tout un témoin qui a
été construit comme un stade donc il
faut montrer aux gens que le veulent
fois c'est pas c'est pas un sport qui
déjà c'est un sport photo j -yi
comprennent que c'est un sport c'est un
superbe jeu mais ça reste un sport c'est
dynamique on marche il ya de l'ambiance
on peut faire des parties incroyable
voilà il ya c'est pas un sport si
guindée que ça c'est pas c'est pas
forcément un entre soi c'est autre chose
c'est vraiment autre chose pour ça il
faut le découvrir font pas hésité à
pousser la porte et que le décor et il
faut venir oui justement de goal com com
comme ceux de 50 à qui exactement fait
ouvert à tout le monde c'est ouvert à
tous et si au début si on arrive on
cerne y allons connaître personne qu'est
ce qu'on fait on arrive ici on dit
bonjour
il faut pas hésiter à poser des
questions à tout les toutes nos équipes
à saint quentin ou chez bluewin de façon
générale sont là pour recevoir les gens
on est là on va discuter avec eux et
essayer de comprendre ce qu'ils veulent
faire ils veulent jouer ils veulent
découvrir on a des solutions et on
essaye à chaque fois de leur proposer la
meilleure solution pour eux alors là il
ya une petite partie alors ils ont des
iso des parapluies faudra compter ce
n'est pas parce qu'il pleut c'est parce
qu'il fait beau oui
c'est la double utilité du parapluie ces
dames se protègent du soleil
effectivement avec les avec les
parapluies voilà ils ont l'air heureux
peut être vous aussi il suffit de venir
ici au bout de cinquante ans on il dit
au fait j'avais oublié quelque chose
l'initiation comment ça se passe et ça
c'est très important effectivement c'est
le premier pas pour entrer dans gulf
tout simplement en s'inscrivant sur
bwin.fr les gens qui sont dans la région
n'hésite pas viens nous voir à saint
quentin nourine point fr et cliquer sur
saint quentin en yvelines et de l'art il
ya plein de créneaux d'initiation
gratuite gratuit gratuite exactement ils
seront encadrés par un professionnel
impro enseignant de golf diplômé d'état
qui va pendant 1h30 2h déjà expliquer ce
qu'on fait qu'est ce que c'est que le
golf comment ça se passe quel est le but
du jeu puis les gens vont taper leurs
premières balles ils vont taper leurs
premières balles sur un green dont ils
vont faire un peu du nikon dans les
vraies conditions d'un vrai quoi si on
va essayer de faire rouler la balle pour
la faire entrer dans le trou puis vont
taper des balles dans un endroit qu'on
appelle le practice le practice ce grand
champ où les gens s'entraînent à taper
la balle et des sept premières dès ce
premier contact avec le golf les donc
les néophytes vont être directement sur
le parcours ils vont faire leurs
premiers trous de golf lac avec le prof
pour vraiment pas directement jodel on
les met dans des conditions de jeu sans
attendre six mois oui moi quand je me
suis tout de suite et ce avec le gros
avantage aujourd'hui avec nos parcours
public 1 et le développement du golf
c'est que souvent on avait parcours
réduit ce qu'on appelle des compacts et
nos débutants au bout de la première
séance des noms ils vont se mettre
réellement au golf ont accès pour
compact dont pourront directement jouer
au golf sur un parcours et du oui parce
que c'est un jeu aussi c'est injecteurs
et des allées des deux trois mois ils
extraient dron grand parcours avec n'est
pas réduit aussi donc très vite ils vont
aller directement jouer au golf parce
qu'effectivement ça va c'est un jeu
devenir fan de ce sport évidemment
j'espère j'espère merci patrice
[Musique]